- My name is Ryan, and
I've never eaten fruit.
It's just something that I've never
wanted to do before this.
My parents have definitely
tried to get me to eat fruit,
but I've absolutely rejected that.
Yup.
I want to eat fruit, because I really feel
like I'll feel better about
myself, I'll look better.
So, I'm here today 'cause I
really want to give it a go,
and I think it's gonna
help me in the long run.
Do you believe in me as my father?
I'm extremely scared.
The texture kind of scares me.
I mean, what's going on
here with this pineapple?
I just don't like fruit.
It's that simple.
But today, I'm gonna risk
it all and try some fruit.
(dramatic orchestral music)
A blueberry?
Is that correct?
I don't like it already.
It's leaking.
It's got a little hole right here.
This is the first time I'm ever trying,
all right, it just leaked out.
Mm, it smells good.
First fruit ever.
Here I go.
That wasn't bad.
I almost gagged at first.
Did you see that?
I really don't have anything
much to say about the blueberry.
I'm not blown away by it.
A five, but I am proud of
myself for trying that,
because
it was small, but it was scary at first.
That's my first fruit.
- [Director] Hell, yeah, all right.
- I just tried a fruit.
- [Director] Good step,
you just tried a fruit,
easy.
- Ugh.
All right.
I know it's a fucking grape, thank you.
Maybe I should cut this in half.
Thank you.
There's that gag reflex again.
See, my eye are watering.
That was like, you bite into it,
and it's just like an
explosion of grapefication.
I would still have to grade it at four.
The blueberry was better.
Next fruit.
It smells sweet.
This is a big piece,
but I'm gonna go for it.
I kinda like that.
I think that's number one so far.
That goes above the blueberry.
I'm gonna give the strawberry a seven.
Oh God.
What the fuck is that?
Okay, what the fuck is this?
This looks like a sea creature.
It smells kinda good.
Oh, oh my God, I hate that.
The texture of this is so weird
that it feels like it's alive.
It's not on the scale.
It's a zero.
Is this a mango?
I like that it doesn't have seeds
or eggs or anything crazy in it.
That's not how I expected it to taste.
It tastes a little like, sour-y.
I was telling my friends, I was like,
"I really think I'm
gonna connect with mango,
"on a different level," and
that's not what happened today.
We were rooting for you, mango.
Oh,
it's an apple.
Doesn't smell like apple
juice right now to me.
That tastes like apple juice.
I, you know, makes sense.
That was, that was pretty, I like that.
I definitely like the crunchier ones.
And now, I can envision
my future with apples.
Like, people dip them in peanut butter.
What else do you have back there?
This is the one that I know
is gonna give me problems.
I do not like banana.
Look at this thing.
This is gonna give me a problem.
I,
I don't like the smell of them,
I don't like the peeling.
I don't
like how obnoxious it looks.
Because I've done so much, and I've
conquered all those fruit, I'm actually
gonna eat this whole thing.
I hate, I hate that.
Too soft.
Too like, gooey, too slimy.
I like orange juice.
This is why I'm so like, messed up.
Hopefully it tastes like a screwdriver,
without the vodka.
Mm, that was good.
I really like that.
Yeah, can I try another piece of it?
This is where I'm at right now.
I have just tried an
orange, a legit orange,
and now, I'm asking for another orange.
Out of 10 I'm gonna give it a 10.
There's a seed in this.
I didn't really like that.
It's a little spongy.
A watermelon is definitely a hard three.
My friend, Carly, is like
obsessed with pineapples.
She always says that I'm gonna love them.
The pineapple is so extra.
Like, can we just take a
second to talk about this.
It smells really good, though.
Mm.
Oh, I'll have another,
if I don't say so myself.
I feel like this is another 10.
This and orange are gonna
be my go to, I think.
(sigh) I did it.
I just tried 10 fruit.
My whole life, I've seen fruit,
I'm like, "I'm not going near that.
"I don't want to try that."
And I just tried 10, so
I'm really proud of myself.
This could open up new possibilities
of trying new foods
with different textures.
So, I just tried 10 fruit.
(laughs)
They almost had to at some point.
(friends cheer)
(triumphant orchestral music)